no doubt in the past you've heard the
adage don't let the best be the enemy of
the good and that's really good advice
but you have to kind of unpack it and
that's what I'm going to do here for
philosophy the reason why I'm shooting
this quick take is because I get so many
questions Earnest ones from people who
have allowed themselves to be let's say
captivated or seduced or dazzled by this
conception of the best and they think
that they need to strive for that and
then they ask me about what the road to
that would be or how to identify it in
philosophy so I get a lot of questions
that have to do with for example the
best translation or the best Edition I
only want to read the best ones right
and you know I've done a whole video
about whether there is in fact a best
translation there isn't typically there
there's just better in certain ways and
worse in certain ways translations that
maybe are less reliable translations
that are more reliable but there isn't
typically a best people also ask me
what's the best approach that I can take
in reading this philosopher this
philosopher or this philosopher how do I
have to you know conceptualize what
they're doing what's what's the best way
to put all of this into some sort of
method that then I can start ticking off
almost like you know a checklist and
people do this as well with where is the
best place to begin in Reading Heidegger
or reading Hegel or reading Nietzsche or
pick whoever else you want right and a
lot of times there isn't actually a best
for that they also do this in terms of
like where is the best place to begin in
studying philosophy as such should I
read this person then this person then
this person then this person
and that's certainly something you can
do but it's not necessarily the best or
the only you know rational way to go
about things and you know there's all
sorts of other permutations that people
get into and so I want to talk about
this a little bit because maybe some of
you viewers or people listening to this
will benefit in in some way
and I'm going to say at the very
beginning that it's good to keep in mind
that this word best right it's what we
call a comparative it's relative to
other things and it's actually what we
call a superlative so it's going to be
at the peak right but it's going to be
at the peak not by itself but in
relation to other things so there's
always some comparison going on there
there's no such thing as the best just
by itself simply so at least in human
Affairs and the other things to keep in
mind is we don't just use this word in
you know that that sort of comparative
superlative way we also use it quite
often to invoke an imagination or an
ideal something that's not real
something that's out there almost in
Utopia It Never Never Land as if it's
you know something
real and this is you know a function of
human language and human thought and
sometimes we get taken in by it it's
also used by a lot of people in what we
could call puffery because you can claim
that something is the best but unless
you're actually qualifying the best in
this way in some demonstrable measurable
manner what you're really saying is kind
of an empty Airy you know feel good kind
of signifier same thing with the worst
people get very hyperbolic about stuff
and it's important to remember that
maybe there isn't a best or a worst you
know and maybe if there are there's a
best in this respect in this respect in
this respect in this range and the same
thing with with the worst as well so
when people are asking for the best in
philosophy or Desiring this as well
right because that's why they're asking
about it they desire it
it's good to keep this in mind so when
we're studying philosophy we will see
philosophers talking about comparative
things right think about Aristotle and
the different kinds of lives right there
is the life pursuing pleasure which is
better than the life pursuing wealth and
then there's a life pursuing honor which
is better than those and then we have
possibly two candidates for the best
kind of life right the most developed
sort of life the life of contemplation
the life of virtuous activity with some
adjuncts friends you know family members
enough wealth to not be destitute and So
within a particular philosophical schema
we see people talking about the best we
see them using this language about good
and about better and best and you know
this this runs throughout a lot of
different uh philosophical positions
but can we do this with philosophy
itself whatever philosophy itself
happens to me that's a whole other vexed
question right oftentimes we're using
this term philosophy and what we really
mean is the bit of it that we've
actually studied ourselves and we're
using it as a stand-in for this vast
vast field and you know pluralistic
activity that's going on that's a whole
other side conversation
there isn't a best for philosophy per se
there's no best philosopher out there uh
in in any way that there would be some
sort of consensus about you know we give
prizes and things to philosophers but
often they're given to those who are
less deserving than those who don't get
the prizes you know that's always a
limited field and similarly there's no
best way to study philosophy there's no
best ordering that you must follow for
you know reading your way through
philosopher where to begin and where to
end or this is not the sort of thing
that actually admits of a real as
opposed to an ideal and imaginary best
philosophy is not the sort of thing that
you're going to optimize that you're
going to metricize or do any of these
these things with even if there are
traditions in philosophy think about
YouTube for example at least that it's
quantitative uh
Incarnation let's call it uh you know
and there's a meta philosophical scope
to utilitarianism as there is to just
about every important philosophy
but you don't have to buy that and you'd
be kind of irrational to to buy into
that as a way to measure philosophy as
such so you know you should also keep in
mind philosophy is not unique in that
way there's no best for a lot of things
in philosophy similarly there's no best
for all sorts of other matters is there
actually a best kind of Cuisine no
there's a whole bunch of cool different
ways of cooking and eating and serving
things out there and they might be best
like maybe you're super into Tex-Mex
food and this person is like an aficiono
of you know Vietnamese pho and stuff
like that that doesn't mean that it's
best as such it just means they happen
to really really like it and maybe it's
best for them in some sort of sense
right there's no best fiction writer
there's no best way to to read Borges or
Philip K dick there's no best way to
actually exercise right if you go into
the gym and the trainer's like this is
the absolute best way for you run away
from that trainer because they're
they're you know selling you something
and either they actually believe it
themselves in which case they're nuts
and you should avoid them or they are
trying to manipulate you they're lying
to you in which case you should avoid
them as well and you know we could go on
and on is there a best way to vacation
is there a best way to pick out your
clothing no none of these things have a
best learning a language you know what's
the best way to get this question a lot
what's the best way to learn Latin or
the best way to learn classic Greek
there isn't a best way there's there's a
lot of different ways that work for
different people I mean it doesn't mean
that we can't say that some things are
probably on the whole going to be more
productive for most people you know and
then there's going to be some outliers
but that's not the best that's not this
unqualified sense that people are asking
about and there's lots and lots of
experts most of whom are really you know
not experts but amateurs in a certain
sense or rather parochial in a way that
I'll talk about in a bit or they're like
selling something they're trying to get
you to buy their coaching platform or
their study platform there's a lot of
people out there who will try to tell
you that when it comes to philosophy
there is a best way to do things you
know a lot of times people belong to a
particular tradition or school and
they've learned things a certain way and
they are convinced that this is the best
for everybody that's like the person in
the gym who's going around correcting
everybody else's exercises and telling
them they need to be on this machine
over here because that's the one that
does the best or they need to be in this
class over here even though you know it
might not be suited to everybody's
bodies or exercise goals
so that's worth keeping in mind that
that set of analogies and comparisons we
can draw I also want to say so what
what's bad about this for you as
somebody who would want to study
philosophy
I think there's a sort of perfectionism
involved in this you know insistence on
the best that is actually quite
counterproductive just like most other
forms of perfectionism turn out to be
what's the problem with perfectionism
well it gets in the way of you doing
things of you actually taking first
steps and then you know the second all
the way up to the thousandth step and
Beyond because you're you're hesitating
before you jump in because you want to
have a priori ahead of time right before
you actually experience anything what is
going to be acknowledged as the best and
you've got no way of knowing that it
even if it was the best that it would be
the case but perfectionism stands in the
way of us getting things done it leads
to procrastination it leads to this
cycle where we feel bad and then we even
you know we want even more to to do
things the right way in in that case
oftentimes it's rooted in reasoning
processes that are not completely
rational that are let's say
not necessarily contaminated but
certainly steered in ways that people
don't fully grasp by their emotional
comportments and their desires and their
affectivity perhaps even traumas that
they haven't worked their way through or
other you know experiences so you know
one common thing fear right fear of
having chosen the wrong way to do
something and then failing as a result
or wasting a lot of your time that
you'll never get back or looking foolish
to other people who are studying things
in a better way or according to a
different method I think sometimes
there's also desire a desire to master
something you don't Master philosophies
it just doesn't work like that you know
you're never going to master stoicism
you're never going to master Aristotle
you're never going to master Hegel
you're never going to master Descartes
these are not
bodies of work that are masterable
doesn't mean that we can't make progress
doesn't mean that we can't say that some
people understand Descartes better than
other people do but
it's not something where you're going to
develop Mastery nobody's going to give
you a badge or you know you've reached
level 27 of the hegelian dialectic or
anything like that it's not like uh you
know this is where gamification is
actually probably standing in the way of
people
being able to study philosophy
adequately you know gamification can
sometimes be a big problem I think some
people are driven in addition to fear or
desire like that they might also be
driven by a kind of Envy or ambition
they're measuring themselves against
other people they're really worried
about where they fit into a hierarchy of
rankings with other people
that's that's not very conducive to
studying philosophy it's not very
conducive to many things again if you go
to the gym you don't need to be looking
at the the person next to you and seeing
how much weight they're doing it doesn't
have anything to do with you and your
body just concentrate on your own
machine in your own weights and your own
exercises and getting yourself there
three days a week and you know
persevering in that I also you know I
use this word parochial a little bit
earlier and what we mean by that are
people who think that they're at the
center of existence when really they're
just in some particular place and they
take the the mores the Norms the
expectations of their time place culture
as if they're universals for all
humankind and people do this in
philosophy all the time you know I knew
people who studied in rather let's call
them rigid programs where where you know
there's a clear narrative about who are
the good guys and who are the bad guys
and why you're studying this you know
for example I had a friend who studied
at the josephineum and so you know of
course he was convinced that Aristotle
and Thomas were you know the most
brilliant thinkers ever and here's the
errors of Kant and Descartes and blah
blah blah blah and he didn't really
understand content Descartes
particularly well but he was very
convinced that the way in which they
studied philosophy was the best way ever
and it just doesn't work like that you
know why not well different people
require different approaches I mean this
is so common sense but you know maybe it
has to be reinforced a number of times
I'm not saying that philosophy is all
just aesthetic choices or you know it's
all up for grabs you know I like Cicero
you like Descartes we all can get along
together that sort of thing no no I'm
not saying that I mean philosophy does
consist in all these conversations where
people are reading each other and saying
no that guy's wrong uh here's why and
that's that's worthwhile but we do have
to recognize not everybody learns in
exactly the same way not everybody's
ready to learn from a particular
philosopher or even a certain body of
their work as opposed to another part of
their work at any given time I mean I
think about myself and what I was able
to read and understand and assimilate
and apply when I was 20 compared to
where I am now at 52 and you know it's
very big difference isn't it so we
shouldn't think that there is anything
like a best overall
per se without
contextualizing it I mean there could be
in fact a best we don't have to throw
the word away but there could be a best
for this person at this time in this
situation given what their background
and experiences is but that best might
be something different tomorrow or a
year from now or in a different context
there is no best as such so you know
what do I want to say we we don't
actually need to make or ask for or rely
upon these determinations of best they
they're really getting in the way early
on you don't know enough to even trust
anybody who tells you that something is
the best just jump in and start doing
things and you'll start figuring out
what works for you better and you know
you'll probably have to reassess that at
different points that's perfectly normal
that's actually desirable and you can
call that whatever you want you can call
that dialectic you can call that a
feedback loop you can call that taking
the lessons from your experience there's
all sorts of vocabularies that you can
put that into but at some point you're
going to have to reassess and that's
perfectly fine and so you get to decide
what works best for you and you can take
advice from people about hey this works
for me I think this is particularly good
maybe stay away from this stuff but it's
up to you what you do with that so if
there is going to be a best it's not
something that somebody else is going to
give you it's going to be something that
you work out for yourself doesn't have
to be in total isolation doesn't have to
be you as the solitary thinker standing
on some Mountain looking down into the
Mist I mean you can do it with other
people you can talk with them you can
you can confer with them you can see
what they have to say but ultimately
it's up to you to work that out for
yourself
there's one other thing that I I think
might be good to bring up maybe you
don't need to have the word the best
maybe it's enough to think in terms of
the better and the worse
or even just the good and the bad this
is good for me I'm going to stick with
this I'm going to work through this see
what's at the other side after I've put
in some you know thought and energy and
try to wrap my head around somebody
else's ways of thinking you don't
necessarily need the best in order for
you to be doing well in order for things
to be good you can even have like I said
evaluation of the better and the worse
but that doesn't entail tying yourself
to this notion of the best and so that's
that's where I'm going to leave off I
think that's enough for me to throw in
front of you right now
um I'm not saying that the best is the
worst or anything like that but these
are some these are some Reflections on
what I've been seeing and my own
responses to it that might be helpful
for you in your studies and processes of
development and growth